hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where right now i have some
pretty
big news to break i got a call from xbox
and then they followed up uh with an
email um
halo infinite is being delayed until
2021.
even though there was a negative
reaction to the halo infinite uh reveal
from a pretty big part of the community
saying that the graphics are terrible of
course there's the craig meme
i was still really surprised to hear
this um i did not expect it especially
considering we were all thinking it was
going to be a launch title for
the xbox series x worth noting uh
xbox did clarify to me that this has no
impact on the release date of the series
x it is coming out in november
it's just that halo infinite itself
won't be shipping
until 2021. to quote the email
it says today i want to share an
important halo infinite development
update with the community
we have made the difficult decision to
shift our release to 2021 to ensure the
team has
adequate time to deliver a halo game
experience that meets our vision the
decision to shift our release date is
the result of multiple factors that have
contributed to development challenges
including
the ongoing covert related impacts
affecting us all this year
i want to acknowledge the hard work from
our team at 343 industries
who have remained committed to making a
great game and finding solutions to
development challenges
however it is not sustainable for the
well-being of our team or the overall
success of the game to ship it this
holiday
we know this will be disappointing to
many of you and we all share in that
sentiment the passion and support the
community has shown over the years has
been incredible and inspiring
we wanted nothing more than to play our
game with the community this holiday the
extra time will let us finish the
critical work necessary to deliver the
most ambitious halo ever
at the quality we know our fans expect
thank you
for your support and understanding um
but yeah they they did you know want to
also touch on the fact that
even though halo infinite's launch
timing is being pushed and the vision at
xbox in three plus three industries has
always been to deliver the most
ambitious halo game ever for fans while
also balancing the team's well-being
um they need more time to finish the the
work etc etc but they they did mention
like all the other stuff that can keep
you busy in the meantime like
thousands of games spawning four
generations on the xbox series x
um and all that good stuff they said
that a big part of this is to
to make some improvements on the game
which is you know something i'm always
always always in support of games being
delayed so that they can be better when
they come out is always going to be
better
than a bad game coming out right on time
um i have no idea when in 2021 they
didn't comment on that but i
guess i would think february march maybe
now
they did also mention a lot of the
issues they've had with working from
home and the pandemic obviously
you know makes it hard to develop video
games as it turns out
i remember making a video right when uh
coronavirus pandemic started
saying that i expected a lot of stuff to
get delayed and it seems like that is
slowly trickling out now
uh but yeah massive news that i didn't
expect to come out of nowhere today
just thought i would let you all know
that's what's up it's crazy
there will be more details on xbox wire
basically at the same time that i
published this video so it should be
12 o'clock pt noon basically that's
about it i'll see you guys next time